so so far we've covered multitask
learning and meta learning topics in the
context of supervised learning as well
as in the context of hierarchical
Bayesian models and so today we're going
to talk about what these types of
algorithms start to look like we move
into sequential decision making domains
in reinforcement learning and so today
we'll get started on that and we'll put
started by talking about kind of a
primer on on reinforcement learning in
the multi task reinforcement learning
problem goal condition variants of that
and then we'll in future lectures over
the next couple of weeks cover
additional topics in the context of
reinforcement learning when you have
multiple goals multiple tasks etc first
time we'll just circle items homework 2
is due on Wednesday this week homework 3
will be out on Wednesday this week and
homework 3 will cover topics in goal
conditioned reinforcement learning and
including some of the things that we're
talking about today and the product
proposal is due next Wednesday ok so
first why should actually care about
reinforcement learning so we talked a
lot about supervised learning supervised
learning is used in a wide variety of
places and I guess first to kind of
answer this question let's think about
well when do you not need sequential
decision-making and anywhere else it
aren't things where you need sequential
decision-making systems so you don't
need sequential decision-making systems
when your system is making a single
isolated decision such as a
classification decision or a progression
decision and where that decision does
not affect future inputs to the system
and does not affect future future
decisions and so from this point of view
we don't need sequential decision
whatever we're kind of in a very
isolated block box world and actually in
the real world in many cases our
decisions are actually affecting the
future or affecting future aspects of
the world so there are many different
applications of sequences sequential
decision making problems in many cases
in some applications people choose to
ignore the dependence of a future of the
current decision on
the future which kind of makes the
simplifying assumption but in many
real-world cases there are there is this
effect of affecting the future and so
for example some very common
applications of reinforcement learning
where you can't afford to ignore this
effect include things like robotics
include things like language and
dialogue systems when you're interacting
with another agent or interacting with a
human for example in autonomous driving
decisions you make affect the future
observations that you make hi business
operations and Finance these are all
kind of in these sequential in a
sequential decision making problem
setting and really most kind of deployed
machine learning systems that are
deployed in the real world and are
interacting with humans are faced with
the sequential decision making problem
okay so this is in practice why this
sort of topic is important and also if
you're interested in kind of how humans
act in the world and how humans are
intelligent in the world these sorts of
problems is also kind of a key aspect of
our own intelligence we also can reason
about how our actions affect the future
okay so reinforcement learning or in
general sequential decision making is
pretty important and so in this lecture
what we're going to talk about is first
what is reinforcement learning or what
does multitask learning look like in the
reinforcement learning context when
you're making sequential decisions what
does this look like in the formulation
of policy gradients which is one one
form of reinforcement learning algorithm
or one class of reinforcement learning
algorithms what does this look like in
the in the context of cue learning so
we'll give a like a few slides of review
on cue learning this should be review
for most of you because this topic is
covered in a number of courses like CS
221 CS 229 etcetera although policy
gradients is not always covered in those
courses so we'll give a little bit more
of an in-depth overview of those and
then finally we'll talk about approaches
for multi task queue learning goal
condition cue learning and algorithms
that that significantly improve upon
kind of a naive approach to multitask
learning in combination with
reinforcement learning
okay so first let's talk about the
problem statement and we can do this by
looking at an example so so far we've
been looking at things like object
classification and regression these
isolate problems where we need to make
predictions and in contrast we can think
about something like optic manipulation
where we have very much a sequential
decision making problem so you can view
the problem of object classification is
a supervised learning problem and the
problem falters manipulation as a
sequential decision making problem and
what are the differences between these
two problems so in supervised learning
so far we've assumed that we have iid
data data that is independently and
identically distributed according to
some distribution where is in sequential
this is making your action that you take
affects the next state that you're in so
the data that you're seeing is very much
not iid a second so in supervised
learning we have some typically assume
some large David dataset this may be
actually curated by humans to ensure
that it has a distribution that you care
about
whereas in things like sequential
decision-making you need to collect the
data yourself in many cases and it's
also not clear what the labels are you
aren't really you kind of need to figure
out what this might be in a different in
different applications and then lastly
and things like supervised learning you
generally have a fairly well-defined
notion of success which is corresponds
to some error or some prediction
accuracy course bought that in relation
to the labels
whereas in things like reinforcement
learning success is a little bit more
gray okay so these are some of the kind
of biggest differences between these two
problem domains and so before we go into
like what concretely a problem looks
like let's look over some terminology
and notation so similar to before we'll
say that we have some neural network
this can be making some predictions and
in the classification setting you might
be looking at an image and then
classifying the class corresponding to
that image of corresponding to different
different types of animals for example
now in reinforcement learning we're no
longer going to be making predictions
like that will be said using our policy
this policy will be taking actions and
the actions will affect the next state
so all right there will be this feedback
loop that goes from the action to back
to the observation and our our classes
won't look something won't look like
this they might look more like this so
we might need to figure out if we should
run away if we should ignore if we
should pet the tiger it's that drug okay
so we need to make decisions oh is
denoting the observation that the agent
or the the system receives input is
noting the action PI is denoting the
policy which is parametrized by theta
and typically we assume that there's
some underlying state of the world s and
so in the fully observed setting we get
to observe us and in the partially
observed setting but you get to observe
oh what concretely is the difference
between s and O one example of this is
you may have you may be trying to chase
a you know or something and if you're
given an image or something that would
be an observation whereas in contrast if
you were given the pose of the
respective animals then that would be
the state you'd basically be able to
fully observe the system the underlying
state of the system and the things that
that matter for making decisions in the
world and in pretty in partially
observed settings you might not just
receive an image you may also have
occlusions in the image or you can
actually see part of the state okay so
this is kind of the the basic kind of
terminology corresponding to
reinforcement learning now one very
basic approach to this sort of
sequential decision making problem is to
treat it as a supervised learning
problem so what you could do is you
could say okay I just want to before I
also want to imitate some expert for
example so maybe you could collect a
bunch of driving data I collect the
observation that the person sees and
collect the action that they took in
those states I put this into some big
training data set and then sample I ID
from the trained is that doing
supervised learning
- to train your policy to predict
actions from observations okay so we've
already actually seen a little bit of
invitation learning so there was a paper
presentation a week or two ago that was
looking at how we can apply meddler into
things like imitation learning these
approaches generally work pretty well in
some contexts for example if you have a
lot of data expert data of performing
the right actions then these these
systems can actually do something fairly
reasonable the place where these kinds
of systems tend to fail are when you
have very long very long horizon
problems you'll have compounding errors
as basically as you make actions you'll
start to move off of the manifold of the
data and then your errors were whole
compound until you're well off of the
manifold of the training data and also
these systems don't reason about
outcomes in any way they're just trying
to mimic what the data is doing rather
than trying to accomplish some
particular outcome okay so this is where
reinforcement learning comes in and for
reinforcement learning we need some
notion of
what's called a reward function and this
reward function should capture what
states and actions are better or worse
for the system so this typically takes
in both a state and an action and it
tells us which states and actions are
better for example if we're driving we
might have a very high reward if we look
like this and have lowered if we see
something like this okay so the in
aggregate the states the actions and the
rewards as well as the dynamics of the
system to find a Markov decision process
this isn't encapsulating the notion of a
sequential decision making problem okay
any any questions up until here they
should mostly be review for people okay
cool
so the goal of reinforcement learning is
typically to learn some policy that
takes as input in this case we'll look
at the fully observe setting takes us
input some state and makes predictions
about actions the goal is to learn that
the policy the parameters of that policy
so for in a deep reinforced
setting your policy will probably be
parametrized as a neural network where
the states are being passed as input
you're pretty producing actions the
actions are fed into the world and then
the world gives you the next state
that's fed back into your policy okay
and so we could actually characterize
the system as the graphical model here
where we have a policy that's taking in
in the in this case and the partial
observe setting a policy that's taking
in the observation and producing an
action the dynamics are taking in the
current state and the current action and
producing a distribution over the next
state and one thing that's pretty
important is that this dynamics function
is independent of the previous state
this is what's known as the Markov
property which is that basically I kind
of the definition of a state in a Markov
decision process is that you can fully
define the reward function and the
dynamics from that the information in
that state variable independent of
previous states and the way the way you
can see that is if you look at this
dynamics distribution here this only
depends on st and 80 and doesn't depend
on st minus 1 okay and then the goal of
reinforcement learning and typically the
kind of the way that we can formulate a
concrete objective here is that we want
to be able to maximize the expected
reward under our policy and in the
infinite horizon case we can imagine the
stationary distribution over states and
actions arising from our policy and
maximize the reward function under that
stationary distribution and then the
finite memorising case we might have
some horizon capital T and we want to
maximize their awards of the states and
actions visited by our policy but
rolling out our policy yeah
it's taken just after so you observe
observation one and then and that's
shown that's shown right here and then
your policy pretty predicts an action
from that observation and that action is
then fed then the kind of the world that
action is actually executed in the real
world and that produces the next state
which produces the next observation so
the I guess there's a couple different
versions of how you might handle the
partial observability maybe one point of
confusion here is the arrow heads on
these arrows are very hard to see and
that there's an arrow going from state
to observation and not an arrow going
from observation to state what your
policy could do is it could try to form
some like estimate of the current state
from your observation and then I'd like
to do some sort of inference and then
pass that to your policy to predict the
next yeah exactly yeah yeah so the state
is the real state okay cool
so now that we've talked about kind of
the reinforcement learning problem what
is the reinforcement learning task and
we're gonna define this for the sake of
thinking about the multitask learning
setting so remember in supervised
learning we defined a task as this as
corresponds the data distribution or the
data generating distributions P of X and
P of Y given X as well as some loss
function in reinforcement learning our
task will be defined as basically just a
Markov decision process so the house
will be defined by some state space s
some action space a some initial state
distribution P of s1 your dynamics
function s prime given s at a and there
a word function so if you look at the
kind of if you compare this to the
supervised learning setting the initial
state distribution the dynamics are
basically the same as the day of
generating distributions the reward
function corresponds to the loss
function and the state and action space
are just kind of telling you what is the
general set that your states and actions
lie with him okay so this is just a
Markov decision process and I guess one
thing worth mentioning here is that if
these if the different MVPs are
different tasks then this is much more
than just a semantic meaning of a task
because different tasks could have the
same exact reward function but have
different action spaces for example or
have different dynamics so we use the
term task loosely to describe these
different Markov decision processes okay
so what are some examples of what
different past distributions might look
like or settings where we might actually
want to apply multis house learning in
the reinforcement learning setting so
one example that we saw earlier actually
as a supervised learning problem but
really is a sequential decision making
problem is a recommendation system or
you want to be able to recommend videos
or recommend treatments or recommend
other things to a particular person and
you can imagine different people as
being different tasks in the system
different people have different
preferences have different operate in
different ways and so if you kind of
view this personalized recommendation
problem as a multi test learning problem
then you can view it as a setting where
the dynamics and the reward function
vary across tasks the dynamics
correspond to how that person will react
to a particular action that you take and
the reward function corresponds to
whether to whether or not what you do
whether or not you recommend something
to them reduce
results in a state that is good in some
context the initial state distribution
may also vary for different people it
depends on the particular like how you
formulate your problem okay so this is
one example another example where
reinforcement learning has been applied
has been in character animation and you
could imagine trying to anim
different characters in computer
graphics across different maneuvers for
example so there's been some work
applying reinforcement learning to
learning for learning maneuvers like
this and in this case if you treat this
as a multi house loading problem
different tasks would have different
reward functions in this setting but the
dynamics would be the same the initial
state distribution would be the same as
well as the state in action space okay
and then another setting where
reinforcement learning has been applied
is for dressing putting on clothes and
this is actually a really challenging
problem in computer graphics because of
the deformable objects I had also has
applications in assistive robotics for
example and in this setting things like
the initial state distribution what what
is the garment what state is the garment
in before you put it on as well as the
dynamics are going to vary across tasks
but the underlying reward function might
be the same such as putting the clothes
on the person and then one last example
of a toss distribution might be if we
want to be able to do reinforcement
learning across different robotic
platforms we may still want to do the
same task across these platforms like
like having them learn how to grasp
things but in this case the state space
in the action space would be would vary
across tasks the initial state
distribution and the dynamics would also
vary across tasks as the robots have
different degrees of freedom and react
to actions in different ways but the
underlying reward function could be the
same of course if you want the robots to
do different things than the reward
function would be different any
questions on these examples or any
questions about other examples okay cool
so this is a reinforcement learning task
now one alternative way to view multi
task reinforcement learning is as
follows so we'll typically have some
sort of task identifier that's part of
the state and this is required to make
it a fully observable setting or fully
observable MDP and the notation I'm
using here is that s bar is going to
denote the original state space or the
original state and di is going to denote
the task identifier as
previous lectures now if you take this
view then interestingly what you can
take is you can look at you can
basically fold looking at the task
identifier in determining determining
the dynamics and returning the reward
into a single dynamics function in a
single reward function and then
basically view your set of tasks as just
a single single task standard Markov
decision process where the state space
and the action space they're just the
union of the state spaces and action
spaces in the original tasks that the
initial state distribution just
corresponds to a mixture distribution
over your initial state distributions
for each of those tasks that dynamics
and the reward function are folded into
the are just a single dynamics in a
single reward function that takes as
input the task identifier and produces
either the next state or the reward so
basically you can essentially view
against basically applies standard
reinforcement learning algorithms
standard single task reinforcement
learning algorithms to the multi task
problem with this view on multi task RL
questions on this
so basically multitask girls the same as
before as the same as the single task
reinforcement problem except we'll have
a task identifier that's part of the
state this task identifier could be
something like a one hot task ID like we
had described in the supervised learning
context it could be a language
description of the task
it could be a desired goal state that
you want to reach and this would be
what's known as goal conditioned
reinforcement learning where you
condition it on a particular state that
you want to be able to reach in the
future and what is there or function
well it could be just the same as before
where it takes us input the task ID and
it outputs the reward function
corresponding to that task for that
state or first things like goal
conditions reinforcement learning it can
correspond to simply the negative
distance between your current state or
your current original state and the goal
state and some examples of distance
functions might be Euclidean distance it
could be Euclidean distance in some
latent space I can also be as far as
zero or one reward function that
corresponds that it's one when s bar
equals SG and zero when they're not
equal okay so you might ask okay if this
is just a standard Markov decision
process why do I'll just apply standard
reinforced paleri algorithms and as I
mentioned you can and this will work
well it will be more challenging than
this than the individual single tasks
because you will have a wider
distribution of things in general but in
general you can apply these same types
of algorithms but you can often do
better and we'll discuss that a bit in
this lecture ok great any questions on
how it can be formulated as a single
task or
yeah so I have you know conditioned RL
is a special case of multitask
reinforcement learning where the task
descriptor corresponds to the goal state
and the tasks correspond to goal
reaching tasks okay so let's get into
some algorithms so the first class of I
guess get so I'll start out by saying
that kind of let's we can look at
broadly a kind of the anatomy and like
the class of reinforcement algorithms
and how these approaches relate to each
other and then I'll talk a bit about two
classes of algorithms so we can
generally view reinforcement learning
algorithms in the following flow graph
where we first are generating samples in
our environment this is just running the
policy forward typically then we fit
some model to estimate the return and
then we use that model to improve the
policy and then different algorithms
typically correspond to just differences
in this green box and then in this blue
box so for example one one example of
fitting a model might be just fitting
something to the return estimating the
empirical return such as using the Monte
Carlo policy gradient another example of
estimating the return might be to try to
fit a Q function by using for example
dynamic programming algorithms and
another example of fitting a model would
be to estimate a function that models
the dynamics and once we have any of
these models we could then for example
apply the policy gradient to our policy
parameters we can improve the policy by
taking the max over key values for our
current Q function or in the case of
model-based algorithms we can optimize a
policy by for example back propagating
through our model into our policy this
is kind of a general outlook on
reinforcement learning algorithms right
we have different choices for fitting a
model to estimate the return different
choices for improving the polls
we also have different choices for how
we generate samples although those are
generally that decision is generally
orthogonal to the choice of algorithm
and in this lecture will focus on model
free reinforcement learning methods such
as policy gradient methods and key
learning methods and in fact we'll will
stick with these algorithms for the next
two weeks about and then on the lecture
on November sixth will focus on
model-based are all methods and how they
can be applied to the multi task set
okay so let's start with policy
gradients so this is our objective in
reinforcement learning so we want to be
able to sample trajectories from our
policy and estimate the return so we'll
refer to this objective as jf theta and
this is just rewriting J or theta you
can view this or you can estimate this
as rolling out and trajectories for
example shown here and estimating the
computing the reward for each of those
directories so maybe the first director
he has a high reward the middle
trajectory has medium reward and the
last trajectory has a bad reward and so
this first sum is the sum over the
samples from our policy and the second
sum is a sum over time so this is a way
that we can kind of estimate the the
expectation shown on the left now what
we could think about doing is can we
differentiate through this objective
directly into our policy so if our
objective is the expected reward and we
can estimate this or where the reward of
a trajectory I'm just using shorthand
you to note that as a sum over time of
the reward function of the individual
states you can view this as this
expectation as an integral over PI theta
because the expectation is with respect
to PI theta of our of tau all right so
this is our objective and if we want to
be able to compute the gradient of this
objective with respect to our policy
parameters we get something like this so
we can move the gradient inside
integral because it's a linear operation
and then we basically have the the
integral of the gradient of the policy
times the reward function integrated
over trajectories okay so this is the
gradient now how do we actually go about
evaluating this gradient so we do we
don't want to have to integrate over all
possible trajectories so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna use this very
convenient identity which is known as
the likelihood ratio trick and in
particular what this identity shows is
that oops
which is that if we are looking at the
the policy parameter sorry that the
policy probability for at Rectory times
the gradient of the log of the policy
this is equal to the obviously just
differentiate through the log this is
equal to the policy times the gradient
of pi divided by pi and of course the
two PI's on the top and on the bottom
can cancel and this is just equal to the
gradient of Pi or the gradient of of the
policy with respect to the pole the
policy parameters okay so we have this
very convenient identity and we can use
it to expand out this equation so we can
basically replace these this term with
the term on the left to get an integral
that looks like this and very
conveniently this integral now looks a
lot like an expectation so this is an
expectation under PI theta and so we can
simply evaluate the gradient or estimate
the gradient by taking an expectation
over over trajectory sampled from our
policy and using those samples to
evaluate the gradient of the log
probability of our policy weighted by
the reward of that trajectory okay so I
guess to recap what we did there this
first trajectory we don't want to have
to integrate over all possible
trajectories and so instead we're able
to transform that into an expectation
over trajectories drawn from the
distribution
of our policy okay
so and then once we have this gradient
we can you can use it but actually
differentiate and compete the screen and
actually apply that gradient to our
policy parameters okay so this is all
with respect to directories one thing
that is one thing that's important to do
is actually break this down into States
and actions
so we're doing the PI of tau as PI of
the full trajectory which can be broken
down into the initial state density
times a product over time of the policy
probability and the dynamics probability
so this is the basically the probability
of directory under our policy if we take
the log of both sides of the equation we
get log PI of theta of tau and then just
change the products into sums using the
log and we can basically plug in the
right-hand side of the equation into the
equation on the left into our form for
the gradient now unfortunately if we
just applied this naively we would have
a term that corresponds to the
probability of our state or next day
given our state in action and we don't
know that probability value but we can
one thing that you know is that because
this this is a gradient with respect to
theta these terms don't depend on theta
they're constant with respect to theta
and so the gradient of theta with
respect to those terms is zero and then
we get so we then get the kind of the
final gradient which corresponds to this
term right here so this is basically log
probability of pi of a given s this is
something that we can't evaluate because
our policy will output a distribution
over a conditioned on us and this right
term is just the reward function given
the state
okay so this is kind of the vanilla
policy gradient and this is something
that we can very clearly evaluate and so
what this looks like as an algorithm is
basically we can estimate easily we can
roll out our policy to get trajectories
we can then estimate the policy gradient
by averaging over those trajectories
over time of the the gradient grad log
pi times the reward function and then
apply the gradient to our policy
parameters so if we go back to our
diagram collecting data corresponds to
the orange box evaluating the return
corresponds to the green box and
actually using that to improve the
policy in the last step corresponds to
the blue box and then what this looks
like as an algorithm which is called the
reinforced algorithm is exclusively
sampling trajectories from your policy
and then computing the gradient using
those trajectories and then using that
estimate gradient to update your policy
parameters and then you can repeat this
step to iteratively improve your
policies okay this is the algorithm how
does this compare to something like
imitation learning like maximum
likelihood of expert actions so if you
look at the policy gradient and you said
also look at kind of the the imitation
learning approach where you do
supervised learning with respect to
actions the maximum likelihood objective
looks pretty similar to the the gradient
of the policy the policy gradient form
and in particular the difference is that
the is just the reward term on the right
so basically policy grading will
correspond to taking maximizing the
probability of actions that have high
reward and if they have low award then
you you'll have a you'll try to maximize
it less essentially
okay no well the really nice things
about this is that because it's just
basically a gradient descent algorithm
it's very easy to apply multitask
learning algorithms to it we can
basically be corresponds very similarly
to maximum like likely the problems so
all the things that we learned about and
maximum likelihood supervised learning
can be applied to the reinforcement
learning context okay this is nice
let's go into it one more slide kind of
on intuitively what this algorithm is
doing so if we look at the kind of the
form of the gradient which corresponds
to the grad log PI of a given s and look
at maximum likelihood we can say that
okay we have trajectories if we do
maximum likelihood imitation learning
we're just trying to imitate the best
trajectories whereas in policy gradient
what we're trying to do is we have some
some distribution over these
trajectories and then we're going to try
to increase the probability of the
actions that had high reward and place
less probability mass on the actions
that had low reward and so as a result
we'll basically just be making the good
stuff more likely making the stuff that
gets bad reward less likely formalizing
this notion of trial and error you try a
few things you do more of the good stuff
and less of the bad stuff okay so that's
policy gradients it's pretty easy to
combine with things like multitask
learning it's also pretty to come pretty
easy to combine with things like meta
learning so the middle learning
algorithms that we learned such as
mammal and black box meta learning
algorithms I just assumed that you can
get some gradient of your objective and
so we can readily apply these two fairly
apply these algorithms to in combination
with policy gradient algorithms so for
example here's a very tight example of
mammal with policy gradients where
there's just two tasks one of the tasks
is running forward and running the toss
is running backwards so we're not
evaluating generalization and in any way
we're just going to look at whether or
not it can learn to adapt its policy
with a single gradient step for one of
these two tasks and what we see is first
at the end of meta learning basically at
this point
right here at the end of my learning but
before taking a gradient step to a one
of the tasks we get a policy that looks
like this it's running in place
essentially if I'm ready to run in
either of the two directions and if we
then take one gradient step with respect
to the task of running backward but
through a warden of running backward we
get a policy that looks like this and if
we take a single policy gradient step
with respect to the reward function of
running forward we get a policy that
looks like this and so I get support of
the interesting things that this shows
is that there does exist a
representation under which reinforcement
learning is very fast and very efficient
at least in the context of a few tasks
and I guess the only thing worth
mentioning here is that the policy
gradient was evaluated with respect to
twenty trajectories from PI theta so
basically 20 trajectories similar to the
video showed on the previous slide ok so
this is pretty straightforward what
about black box methods so we can also
apply policy gradient to black box
methods what this corresponds to is
using some lsdm policy some policy with
memory or recurrence and training that
policy with the policy gradient
algorithm or a variant of a policy
gradient algorithm that I mentioned on
the previous slide so for example in
this previous paper that was actually
presented a few weeks ago in class one
of the experiments that they looked at
was learning to visually navigate a maze
and so what they did is they trained the
algorithm on a thousand different small
mazes and then evaluated the algorithms
ability to learn how to solve new mazes
I've seen both small mazes and large
mazes and so we can look at what it does
so here this is first showing after meta
learning at the beginning of rolling out
the recurrent policy so in this case it
doesn't know the task and it needs to
navigate the maze and the left is
showing the the agents point of
and the right is showing the maze and
then after it gets this experience it
then is able to learn how to solve the
maze with basically just a single
trajectory so at first navigate around
that maze to explore and then at the end
of that episode the memory of the of the
architecture is not reset and you keep
on rolling forward that that memory at
that blackbox architecture and it can
figure out how to from there based on
what store memory how to solve the task
and they also looked at bigger mazes so
here's an example of it navigating
through a bigger maze at the beating is
just exploring it needs to figure out
how to solve the task so it explores
different parts of the maze this is one
of the D I guess both of these examples
are successful examples there's also
failure cases so here's one in this case
after it sees a single directory is able
to very quickly navigate to the goal
position okay yeah yeah
so from mammal the number of the the
inner loop corresponding to 20
trajectories and one grade one policy
gradient step in this example the inner
loop corresponds to basically like two
trajectories where you could spacely see
the trajectories on the on the thing so
here's the this is the first trajectory
shown here and then the second
trajectory is when it actually solves
the task well does that answer your
question this is after meddler yes yeah
so this is the inner loop yeah and then
the outer loop is trained a lot for
across the different house this is
trained across a thousand mazes during
the Mediterranean process and then yeah
and it practices a lot for those mazes
yeah
yeah so in this case it's just gets this
as input it doesn't get the the layout
of the maze and in the case of the ant
example it just receives like joint
angles and other state information yeah
so in both these examples after this end
of the first trajectory it just it's it
is reset to the additional position so
that answer your question
so I think that it after it reaches the
end here it is then reset to this
position again we can watch it again one
more time if you want to verify so he
goes to the goal and then it's respawned
right there again yeah yeah that's a
good question
so I guess as of like last year I think
that these sorts of maze tasks are
probably the most complicated tasks that
I've seen these algorithms do this year
I've seen more complex tasks that these
algorithms have been able to learn
quickly ranging from being able to adopt
to learn how to run on an entirely new
agent or like a simulated robot to
solving like actually settings were the
tasks themselves were partially
observable not just the is this is this
is also partially observable but
partially observable to a greater degree
I guess and then I've also seen tasks
where it's like they're different
manipulation tasks and it can generalize
to an entirely new manipulation tasks
like robotic manipulation tasks but
those are those are all like very very
recent works but yeah it's they're more
more more better things to come yeah
yeah so this is a good question well so
we'll cover metal reinforcement learning
in more detail next week on Wednesday
when there's going to be a guest lecture
by Kate but one thing that I'll say here
is I guess first one of the things in
the reinforced more exciting we talked
about how a mammal is very expressive in
the supervised learning setting in the
reinforced learning setting it's
actually not very expressive because
because of the policy gradient basically
if the reward function is zero for all
of your trajectories then your gradient
will always be zero and so even if it
gets lots of rich experience about the
environment with zero reward it can't
actually incorporate that experience to
update the policy and that's does this
just one example there's other examples
where the policy create isn't very
informative and so as a result mammal
with policy gradients isn't actually
very expressive and has well is is yeah
it's not it's good the in general
applying these algorithms to the
reinforcement learning setting it's
pretty easy to combine with policy
gradients combining them with methods
like key learning and actor critic
algorithms is a lot more challenging and
Kate will talk about that certainly a
lot during her lecture and some of the
challenges that come up there the
biggest thing is that those algorithms
aren't a gradient based algorithm
they're a dynamic programming algorithm
so it's harder to combine these things
yeah yeah so curiosity based approaches
and other exploration methods in general
can certainly be combined like that's
just a kind of an objective and you
could use that objective as one of your
tasks you can augment all of your tasks
with that objective or you could imagine
trying to learn exploration strategies
like learn curiosity like learn
different forms of curiosity that are
particularly effective for a class of
tasks or class of environments and Kate
will talk about kind of learning
exploration strategies in a lecture next
week yeah
advantage estimation you mean I'm GAE
generalize advantage mission yeah so the
I guess sirs there's different there's
different ways so I guess to explain to
other people kind of what the question
is so one of the challenges with policy
gradients is that the gradient estimate
that it gives you as high variance and
one thing that people typically do to
mitigate to reduce the variance of this
is to use what's called a baseline which
corresponds to some which basically
corresponds to which is something that's
subtracted from the reward term here it
is gives you an unbiased estimate of
this gradient but that has lower
variance and there are different
techniques for estimating that baseline
and one of them corresponds to things
like generalize advantage estimation and
other things in the original
implementation of de mammal algorithm we
used a Monte Carlo estimator for the
baseline rather than a bootstrap
estimator
I think applying a bootstrap estimator
would be like applying mammal to that
would be a bit tricky you could of
course always do it from scratch on your
batch of data but applying mammal to it
is a little bit tricky because just
because of how because bootstrapping
isn't a great name based algorithm it's
a dynamic programming algorithm yeah
it's hard
okay so some of the pros of policy
gradients to recap is that it's very
simple I gives you an it kind of just
gives you a gradient of your policy
which is very nice it's also very easy
to combine with existing multitask
algorithms and meta learning algorithms
as we saw in the last couple slides the
downsides is that first it produces a
high variance gradient and this can be
mitigated with baselines and baselines
are basically used by all algorithms and
practice I don't have time to cover them
in this lecture but feel free to come to
office hours if you're interested in
learning more it could also be mitigated
with trust regions with which people
have also used and both of both mammal
and the black box methods were using
both baselines and trust regions in the
optimization to make things more stable
and more effective the other downside of
policy gradient algorithms is that it
requires on policy data and in
particularly the way that you can see
this as you can see this is expectation
it's with respect to pi theta and pi
theta is your current policy so in order
to improve your policy you need data
from your current policy and this is
really important because this means that
you can't reuse any data from your
previous policies to estimate to try to
improve your policy it also means you
can't reuse data from other tasks or
from from other things basically and
this is this is really challenging as a
result these algorithms tend to be less
sample efficient than algorithms that
are able to reuse data from previous
policies from from other experience at
cetera things like importance weighting
can help with this so you can basically
add a weight that that is corresponds to
the ratio between the policy between
your current policy and the policy that
you collected data with but these
importance ways also tend to give you
high variance especially when those two
policies are very different okay cool so
now that we talked about policy
gradients let's talk about value-based
reinforcement learning I
particular the the benefit of
value-based RL is that first they they
tend to be lower variance by introducing
some amount of bias and they can use off
policy data which is the bigger which is
like a really important thing if you
care about reusing data and being sample
efficient okay um so for a very brief
overview of these algorithms for those
of you who are a little bit rusty so a
value function first let's go over some
definitions so a value function
corresponds to the total reward that you
will achieve starting from state s and
following some policy PI so this is a
function of both the policy and your
current state and a cue function oh it's
in this kind of captures how good is a
state basically how valuable is that
state and a key function corresponds to
the same thing as a value function but
the total reward starting from state s
taking action a and from there following
PI so the a that's passed as input is a
parameter and it does not depend on the
policy PI and this is basically telling
you how good is a state action pair both
of these things are very closely related
so as I alluded to the value function
corresponds to an expectation over
action the value function for current
policy corresponds to the expectation
under a policy of Q of the stays input
and the pulp the action samples from
your policy and one of the things that's
really nice about your Q function is
that if you know the Q function for your
current policy you can use it to improve
your policy so for example one very
naive way to see this is that if you
just set the probability of taking an
action for your current state to 1 for
every action that is the max of the arc
max of the Q value this is just going to
increase the probability of taking
actions that have maximum Q values then
the new policy resulting from this will
be at least as good as the old policy
and typically better okay
so the gold value based RL is to learn
these to learn at least the key function
and then use that key function to
perform the task or to perform order to
learn a policy and one kind of critical
identity that's important for these
types of algorithms is noting that for
the optimal policy we have this equality
that is satisfied so we know that the Q
function for the optimal policy is equal
to the expectation of states visited
under the dynamics of the reward
function plus gamma times the max of
actions of the context Q function where
gamma here is representing some discount
factor and the way that you can see this
is that basically if you take a reward
and then if I take current times if you
observe some reward and then you know
kind of the the kind of the reward in
the future for the best action that's
going to equal the best the best value
from your current state and current
action and this is what's known as the
bellman equation okay
so we can use this moment equation to
learn a key function so what this looks
like is this is one example of an
algorithm that's called fitted Q
iteration and what this looks like is
you first collect a dataset using some
policy and the hypo parameters
corresponding to sort of the data set
size and the policy that you use for
data collection you can then set the
reward plus the max Q as some target
label and then improve your policy to
try to match those target values so
you're essentially trying to run a
dynamic programming algorithm that leads
to the bellman equation holding for your
Q function and so for example if your Q
function is represented has parameters
Phi that might be some neural network
that takes us input the state and
auction and
puts the q-value a scalar value for that
state and auction
another way to parametrize this in
discrete action cases is if you just
pass in the state and then output the Q
value for each of the actions correspond
for that state and that's that's often
used in practice and the other type of
parameter values like that that you have
in this algorithm correspond to the
number of gradient steps you take and
the number of iterations that you
perform this form some practice you're
going to be iterating between collecting
a dataset computing your target values
trying to fit your Q function to those
target values and then iteratively
fitting your Q function and also
recollecting your data set okay and then
the result of this procedure is that you
get you can get a policy by simply
taking the Arg max of your Q function
for a given state so take the actions in
the current state that maximize your
future reward or your future returns
okay so this is a Q learning style style
algorithm some important notes here
first we can reuse data from previous
policies so this doesn't make any
assumptions about the underlying
algorithm there's no expectations with
respect to PI theta in any of this and
so as a result it's what's called an off
policy algorithm because that you can
use off policy data and as a result you
could use replay buffers so you can
store data you can aggregate data across
all of your experience into a single
replay buffer and when computing this
update you can load from your replay
buffer any kind of any source of data
and this allows you to one kind of keep
on aggregating data and we're using that
data and to get more data that is D
correlated so if you just kind of get
some data online and then make updates
you'll have very correlated data which
will result in poor performance okay
another thing to note as I mentioned
before is that this is not a gradient
descent algorithm this is a dynamic
programming algorithm and you can see
that by the
that this this update affects the
targets at the next value right here and
as a result it's tricky to kind of
combine this approach with things like
mammal and and even black box methods in
practice but it is relatively easy to
combine with algorithms like multitask
learning algorithms and gold condition
learning algorithms by simply
conditioning your q function or your
policy on the task identifier or the
goal okay so let's talk about multitask
you Larry
any questions on kind of the setup for
key learning before I move on okay so
for multitask RL we can just kind of
take our policy and condition it on some
task identifier likewise for our Q
function and in each of these cases I'm
using again using s bar to denote the
kind of original state space where the
kind of the the new augmented state
corresponds to the original state space
the task identifier analogous to
multitask learning we can use a lot of
things that we've learned about before
like stratified sampling like hard and
soft weight sharing other architectural
changes etc so this is quite nice we can
reuse the things that we've learned
across supervised learning and
reinforcement learning know what's
different so there are some things that
are different that about reinforcement
learning that we talked about at the
very beginning of the lecture that
effects the algorithm choices that we
make so the first thing that's different
is that the data distribution is
controlled by the agent it's no longer
just given to us all right and so one of
the things we can think about is can we
reuse that can we think about how how to
weeks for data in a way that is
effective for multiple tasks and also
can we think about not just weight
sharing but also data sharing across
tasks and how should we when we collect
about your data how should we choose to
share that data across the tasks and
second you may
so know what aspects of the MDP are
changing within your toss distribution
and if you know this you can actually
leverage this knowledge in certain ways
in your algorithm choice by making
assumptions about whether or not one
aspect of the MVP is going to be
changing across tasks okay so let's
think about an example for thinking
about how we can how we might want to go
about sharing data or leveraging the
sort of information so say we are
playing hockey and we have some some of
our teammates and some of our opponents
and we may want to be trying to practice
different tasks so we may want to be
able to practice passing the puck from
from yourself to your teammate and you
may also want to be able to practice
shooting goals know if you're
considering this voltage house learning
problem what if during practice you
accidentally perform a very good pass to
your to your teammate when you're trying
to shoot a goal well this happens I it
makes sense of course to store your
experiences normal but you could also
take that experience and say well okay
even though I was trying to shoot a goal
I don't need to just use that for
shooting a goal I can also say okay in
hindsight if I was doing toss to eye
that would've been great I would have
gotten a kind of a very high reward for
that task right and so you can real able
that experience with the task to
identifiers and with the reward function
for that task and store that data for
that task okay so this is something
that's known as hindsight V labeling
which is that in hindsight you can kind
of take some experience that you
collected with the intention of one task
we label it for another task and use
that in learning the other task okay all
right it's also referred to sometimes as
hindsight experience replay as well over
her okay so what does this actually
formally look like so we can look at
imagine a goal conditioned RL setting
and first we're collecting some data
using some policy as in the kind of
standard policy reinforcement learning
setting
then we for store the data in a replay
buffer and then we perform hindsight
relabeling so what we can do is we can
take we can we label the experience that
we just collected but take the last
state that we actually reached and
imagine that that was actually the goal
for that task so we can replace the
replace of that goal that you were
trying to achieve in that task with the
goal that you actually achieved and
replace the reward function with the
distance between the current state and
that new hindsight goal and then once
you have this rule able to experience
you can then store that in your replay
buffer as well and then of course update
your policy using your replay buffer and
repeat okay cool so what about other
relabeling strategies so what this would
be labeling tried to use the last goal
as input as other thing that were the
last state is the thing that we're going
to label is the goal you can also use
really any state from the trajectory and
those are also states that were reached
and in general you can you could choose
any potential State to read label with
although in practice one of the things
that's really nice about relabeling with
a state that you actually reached is
that it can alleviate it can alleviate a
lot of the a lot of the exploitation
challenges so if you're exploring for in
the context of one task versus in the
context of many tasks if you
accidentally solve one task when trying
to perform the other tasks then you've
already then you've solved the
exploration problem for that task this
can also kind of bootstrap the kind of
it allows you to kind of bootstrap the
learning process okay any questions on
how this works
so we can generalize this also to the
multitask RL setting and this is kind of
similar to the setting that we showed in
the example so the way this looks like
is we just in this case we just have a
me clock data in this case the data core
has a task identifier rather than a goal
state we store that data we real able by
four by selecting some task J replacing
the task identifier with the task
identifier for task J and then replacing
the ward function with the Ward's sorry
that should be the negative shouldn't be
there but this replacing it with a
reward function for task J of the
corresponding state and then storing the
V label data updating the policy and
repeating another question that comes up
here similar to the last slide is what
tasks should choose to real able with
you choose randomly but one good choice
in terms of exploration is you could
choose tasks in which the trajectory
achieves high reward and that will help
you those are tasks that that's all the
exploration problem to some degree for
those tasks yeah yeah we'll talk about
that in a few slides
yeah
um yeah so if you initially collected
there were the data if you did collected
the data for tasks I you would get
reward labels for tasks I and then if
you want to be label for task J here
then you you you want to kind of replace
the reward function in that cuz
experience with rewards that would
correspond to toss J does that answer
your question
all right
now you can't always apply this trick so
you can apply relabeling when the form
of the reward function is known and this
is and evaluatable if you can't evaluate
the reward function in all possible
contexts or it's expensive to evaluate
the reward function like if it if it
requires asking a human for example it
may be a bit trickier to do this it also
requires that the dynamics be consistent
across goals or tasks that you re label
for if they're not consistent then when
you have to post corresponding a state
action and next state those tuples will
no longer be dynamically consistent and
the resulting policy you get will have
data that corresponds to different
dynamics that isn't accurate this is
kind of one example of exploiting the
knowledge that we may know that there
were a McPhee the same across tasks and
you also need to be using an off policy
algorithm within a strict that I believe
that there are some people that have
looked at applying this and on policy
settings but basically if we're gonna be
relabeling experience for this task and
storing this and a replay buffer like we
don't have the we don't necessarily have
the policy that that collected this
experience
when it was passed in a particular goal
state to come up with multiple because
on the right there you asked which task
to choose could you say that let's come
up with a few different ones yeah so I
mean maybe I'm not maybe one in surgery
but you can tell me if it answers your
question or not is this is I guess what
I was making this line I was assuming
that you would have an initial set of
tasks that you cared about they're males
to be a setting where you just have one
task that you care about and you want to
leverage other tasks to improve the
learning for that task and in that
setting it is important to think about
wall can we construct other like
exhilarate asks for improving and that
will be something that is discussed a
bit actually on Wednesday in the paper
presentations go
yeah so you could certainly basically
choose tasks at random and or just like
tease all the tasks essentially and that
yeah you could certainly do that and
then like you could essentially view
this version like task one where sub
structure gets forward as a form of that
where you just relabeled all of them and
then we new sample data from your replay
buffer you prioritize it to include data
that we're in which you get high reward
for example so yeah you could you could
definitely do that and then think about
how you might prioritize later I guess
one downside of doing that is you do
have to prioritize potentially or
I guess it kind of depends on the
setting but yeah typically if you did
that you would probably want to
prioritize so that you're not getting a
ton of data that you just have zero
reward because your policy was
attempting completely different things
okay
so let's we can just look at one kind of
quick empirical example of what this
looks like in practice so the paper from
2017 was looking at this goal condition
RL in the context of simulated robotic
manipulation where there are tasks such
as pushing shown in the top row sliding
shown in the middle row and pick in
place shown in the in the bottom row I'm
looking at this now I'm not sure what
the difference between pushing and
sliding is but maybe maybe that's the
kind of details around the paper and
then Pyrrhic lee if you look at without
relabeling versus with relabeling they
took a value based on all method called
DD PG and the green and dashed red lines
so show DD PG without relabeling and the
red and blue lines show with relabeling
with two different relabeling strategies
and you can see that in in these
settings we labeling significantly
improves performance likely mostly
because of an exploration challenge so
you see that in the pushing example and
in the pick-and-place example the
original DD PG is basically getting no
reward which means that it's having
trouble actually finding any rewards and
so this approach is helping it find
rewards for something for certain goals
by essentially amortize an exploration
across the different tasks
okay cool
and then since we have a bit more time
we can talk a bit about image
observations which is one of the
questions asked before so one of the
things that's that's important in the
goal condition Durell setting is you
need this distance function that tells
you how far you are from your state and
this is this corresponds to your award
function but when you have the image
observations you don't have good
distance functions for images in general
I things like like Lt distance don't
work very well and so one thing you
could imagine doing is well what if you
have a binary reward function that
basically is just one if the two images
are identical and zero otherwise um this
will be accurate but of course it will
be very sparse but there are things that
even though as far as there are things
that we can do with it and things that
we can ways that we can use this for
effective learning in a particular one
of the things that we can observe is
that under the sparse binary reward
function we know that random interaction
that's unlabeled is actually optimal if
your goal function is to reach the last
state the last time set so for example
if you have some agent that's randomly
kind of exploring in the world you can
say that okay this is optimal if all we
care about is reaching here at the last
time stuff and we don't care about any
of the other time steps and how we got
there and so there are things that you
can do to actually you can kind of
leverage this insight with a couple
different algorithms so the first thing
you can do with this well first it means
it's easier to deal with image
observations because we can use the zero
one reward function the first thing you
can do is you can use it for better
learning so if you know the data is
optimal with the spec of that reward
function what if we just use supervised
imitation learning on that data so an
imitation learning means typically
assume that we have optimal
demonstrations I here if that's a reward
function these random interactions for
gold condition or L correspond to
optimal behavior and so what we can do
is we can collect data from from some
see perform hindsight relabeling where
we use the last state as the goal in
hindsight store the read label data and
some replay buffer and then update your
policy just using supervised imitation
learning conditioned on the real abled
goal on your replay buffer so it turns
out you can do this and it actually does
decently well in a number of domains one
paper that did this the way that they
collected data was actually by using
data from a human that was kind of
interacting in not completely random
ways but in more directive ways but
still in less optimal ways as you might
think
so they collected data from human play
and perform goal condition imitation
learning on this data so here is an
example of the the play data so this is
just a human doing a bunch of random
stuff in this environment in virtual
reality
and this data there's no reward
functions in this data or anything but
what you can do is you can take some one
of the kind of states in this thing you
can train a goal condition function
basically a policy that takes us and put
a goal image and the current image and
regresses to the actions that the human
took for different windows of this data
and as a result you get a policy that
looks like the bottom right that is able
to reach goals including pressing
buttons for example that's trying to
press the green button trying to press
the blue button now it's trying to slide
the door over to the left it's able to
do kind of all of these different goals
just by using that that data okay are
there any other ways to use this insight
so another thing that we could do with
this insight is we could try to use it
to learn a better goal representation so
if we have a zero one goal
representation this isn't very good for
reinforcement learning but we can use it
to learn a better goal representation
and in particular we can imagine the
question which representation when uses
a reward function will cause a planner
to choose the observed actions and so we
could first collect random unlabeled
interaction data in this case
we'll collect data of just a robot like
sampling from a random Gaussian
distribution as shown here
I will then train a latent state
representation and a latent space model
such that if we plan a sequence of
actions with respect to the last state
we recovered the observed action
sequence so essentially this corresponds
to embedding a a planner in latent space
into a goal condition policy and train
that goal condition policy with
supervised learning to match the
observed actions so we can use this
policy directly as in the previous paper
but we can also throw away the latent
space model and return the global
representation that the planner was
using the planner was using inside that
policy and combine that that goal
representation with reinforced for
learning so this is referred to as
distributional planning that works in
the sense that it's performing this
planning procedure inside the neural
network and outputting a distribution
over action sequences and what you can
do with this metric as this metric is
the metric that it gives you is much
more shaped because the planner has to
be able to use that shape reward
function if you only gave it the sparse
reward function it wouldn't be able to
succeed you can do this you can take out
this metric run reinforcement learning
with the speck of this metric on a
variety of vision based robotic learning
tasks and then compare to a variety of
other metrics such as pixel distance and
distance in it being 'late in space and
you can see that the metric that comes
from this procedure is shown in green
leads to much more successful
reinforcement learning because it's able
to recover both an accurate and a shaped
reward function and so you can get
behavior that looks like this where it
can figure out how to reach an image of
goal or figure out how to push an object
to reach an image of a goal and it could
also be used in the real world for like
reaching a certain goal image or for
pushing an object for example okay so to
summarize what we talked about today is
what is the multi task control problem
how we can we apply policy gradients to
this problem and how we can think about
doing weight sharing as well as data
sharing in both policy gradient settings
and in cue learning settings
so there's a number of remaining
questions some of which you brought up
today that we'll cover in the next two
weeks so for example can we use
exhilarate asks to accelerate the
learning process and this will be the
focus of Wednesday what about
hierarchies of tasks where we have
subtasks and then we want to learn
higher-level policies that operate on
those subtasks can we learn exploration
strategies across tasks rather than
using a single kind of just using
vanilla you know approaches and also
what do metal our algorithms actually
learn when applied to various settings
so we'll be covering each of these the
first will be covered on Wednesday in
the paper presentations the second one
will be covered on Monday next week in
table presentations next Wednesday we'll
have a guest lecture by Kate Rick Kelly
who is the first author on a recent off
policy meta RL paper that is I think
currently the state of the art method in
metal reinforced learning and that on
Monday we'll we'll have paper
presentations that study emergent
phenomenon in meta reinforcement
learning for those of you that don't
have quite as much experience in
reinforcement learning there are
additional reinforcement learning
resources such as the Stanford course
the UCL course from David silver and the
Berkeley course and I believe that all
these courses have lecture videos online
so if you're interested in learning more
of those could be helpful and you could
also be useful for the homework and then
a couple reminders homework 2 is due on
Wednesday homework 3 covers hindsight
experience replaying goal condition daro
and that will be out this wednesday and
due in a couple weeks after that and
then the project proposal is due next
Wednesday okay see you on Wednesday